hello everyone and welcome back to the
London chess classic we have a real
treat for you in this one it's a sort of
A Feast for the eyes and the Soul as it
features the Berlin defense it's Andre
volokitin Ukrainian Grand Master against
Hans miman and uh the Berlin defense is
a really weird opening it gained a lot
of popularity in the in the year 2000
when uh World CH Championship Challenger
Vladimir Kik used it very successfully
against the den world champion Gary
Kasparov uh without allowing um Kasparov
to win a single game with the wide
pieces That's How Strong it was Kasparov
even had to deviate from uh from uh
trying E4 he he he also had to employ
other openings uh but over the course of
the a couple of games where it was used
the Kik was just so incredibly solid
that uh uh you know 15 games without a
single win that's against casparo that
is absolutely amazing uh he won I think
um the second game and also one other
game so just he he won two games against
Kasparov and just won the match became
world champion and ever since then it's
been uh used in all sorts of ways it's
been used to get very quick draws it's
been used surprise your opponents if you
guys remember uh in 2018 candidates
tournament Vladimir Kik again used it
with the black pieces against leevon
Aran and he completely obliterated him
with that G5 line if you haven't seen it
do check it out will be the first link
in the description below but yeah
everyone uses it in all the time formats
you know if you guys enjoy it uh um you
will love this game uh so let's see how
hunts played it against Andre here
because uh well even when you think
nothing is happening something is
happening so let's check it out Andre
has the white pieces he opens with Pawn
to E4 uh we already advertised the
Berlin defense so let's go the Lopez is
on the board and Knight to F6 the Berlin
defense uh we have castles Knight
captures on e4 and now Pawn to D4 the
Rio Gambit accepted also the main line
of the Berlin Knight to D6 B Bishop
captures D captures and D captures on E5
so the Queens come off the board Knight
to F5 and now Queen captures on d8 and
King captures on d8 and this is where uh
usually these games begin where white
has to decide on how to continue the uh
the the top move here is Knight to C3 uh
but if you're wondering about Rook to D1
check and Bishop to G5 check you can
play them but they're really nothing
it's very easy for black to consolidate
okay you have to move the king one more
time but let's say after Knight to C3
Bishop is or even if you threaten
Checkmate doesn't matter just Bishop D6
so Bishop D6 and now after let's say
Rook a to D1 uh already after Bishop to
B4 white will be having some problems
here because well this is just very
annoying and if you move the Knight and
Bishop to D5 already black is in control
of the entire board so you can just play
whatever so you have to play it
correctly H3 is the second most popular
move here Bishop to E7 trying to trade
off this Knight with Knight to H4 and
now Knight to C3 we have Knight to H4
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
just nicely developed developing with
Bishop to E3 uh Pawn to H5 Hans wants to
bring back the bishop and then Advance
the pawn to H4 to control the king side
you don't want to allow any unnecessary
expansion Here and Now Knight to E2 Rook
Rook to D1 check is by far the most
popular but here um Andre goes for a
different plan Knight to E2 and now
again there are games in this position
Bishop D7 a well-known game between
karakin and maxxim Vash from the 2018
Batumi Olympia that ended in a draw uh
but here we have King to E8 by hunts and
it is now as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so okay Pawn to F3
setting up for that G4 Pawn push and now
Bishop goes back to E7 hunt of course
he's hoping to play H4 to prevent G4 uh
but Andre beats him to it so G4 and now
you could capture and it seems like a
very good idea to have your Rook control
the H file although there doesn't seem
to be all that much uh you can do after
this so hunt Waits with it after this
Pawn to the G4 Pawn push he plays Pawn
to F5 he puts more pressure on the G4
Pawn so now e captures on F6 alasa but
not Bishop captures the move you'd
expect to uh go after the the B2 Pawn
which probably objectively is the best
uh then white has to play something like
Bishop to D4 bishops get traded off and
it's a nice position instead he goes for
G captures and F6 he goes for sort of an
unbalanced position where he will look
for his chances uh in the semiopen OR
soon to be open G file with have Knight
to F4 uh eyeing that G6 square and Hans
just trades on G4 H captures on G4 F
captures on G4 now the Knight is
guarding the H3 pawn and now Pawn to F5
and it looks like uh you've accomplished
everything you're going to trade on G4
you're going to develop the bishop get
the Rook into the game however there's
Rook a to E1 and now your king being in
the center doesn't really do you all
that many favors to give you an example
if F captures on G4 Bishop to C5 and
black resigns already it's game over you
can defended once but then the Knight
attacks it again and black is unable to
deliver more more Defenders to the E7
Bishop so after Rook a to E1 Hans has to
unpin King to F7 and now Bishop to D4
goes after The Rook Rook to d8 goes
after the bishop and now Hans is banking
on after this is settled by moving the
bishop or something he can play Rook
back to G8 or he can even trade on G4
not likely as The Rook is on F1 so
probably just Rook back to G8 but here
Andre beats him to the punch he play
Rook captures on E7 with check King
captures and now Bishop to C5 check so
he gets the bishop out of Harm's Way and
now if you're wondering what's the idea
behind the exchange sacrifice well the
idea is that now after you move out of
check Pawn to G5 so you sacrifice The
Exchange but you will get two connected
pass pawns on the king side uh which uh
you know is definitely compensation in
itself and now uh the cleanest way to
handle this uh uh this uh sort of um uh
insolence by Andre is to play B6 uh
everything has to come with Tempo and
after the bishop moves Bishop to A6
attacks The Rook also comes with Tempo
after The Rook moves now you counter The
Rook you bring the other Rook into the
game you've developed everything and
hopefully you can defend against those
pawns that's objectively best but here
hunt played Rook to G8 also comes with
Tempo but now after H4 he went for bshop
to E6 and this is now a problem perhaps
B6 was still a plan but after Bishop to
E6 the game is now completely winning
for Andre uh but you have to find the
correct idea now what did Hans miss here
and uh why is it such a difficult
position to hold feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move for Andre uh while I give you a
couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
realizing the power of the past pawns
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is King to F2 uh this
is the move that Andre played and I'm
sure when Hans saw this he realized what
was what was coming or maybe he saw it
even before he played his previous move
but he maybe thought Andre would not
play it but now as the Knight already
guards G6 you know the king just freed
up the square for The Rook will control
a G6 additionally and now G6 will be a
terrible threat to face then of course
H6 H5 H6 and so on and now the question
is how does Hans stop this uh does he
just continue development and he allows
this Rook to G1 idea uh we have to we
have to see what happens there if he
goes Rook a to d8 okay you you go after
Rook to D2 check of course white will
stop this bishop to E3 and then you're
pretty much out of moves let's say you
go back because you don't want the
bishop hanging here all the time so
Bishop back to C8 now Rook G1 and after
let's say King to G7 H5 is coming now
you might play something like Rook to D6
G6 is coming and once you move the Rook
let's say Rook E8 uh even H6 with check
and black pretty much resigns here
there's nothing to to do here you either
allow the pawns to advance further or
you capture here and now look at this
Knight E6 check the King has to go down
the board King to H5 Knight G7 check
again the King has to go down the board
Bishop G5 check King has to go down the
board Rook to G3 check King has to go
down the board and now you captured The
Rook but of course your main idea is to
Checkmate the black king even if Rook
captures on G6 there's even Knight back
to F6 there's really no move for white
here uh black here as white is up a
piece but just to give you a a fancy way
to finish things you can even play
Knight to G4 sacrifice the Knight for
this beautiful Checkmate Bishop to F4
and now there's no defense Rook to G2
will be a double check and then King H3
let's say whatever you play Rook G2
check King H3 Rook to H2 will be
Checkmate so whatever you play here uh
will be lost if you allow this these
pawns to advance forward so of course
Hunt is very resilient he finds Rook to
G6 and he hopes that Andre captures it
so he can can put his King here and stop
the advancement of the pawns uh but of
course you will not do that Andre plays
Rook to G1 now H5 is a threat as G5 is
no longer hanging so Rook 8 to G8 now
again stopping H5 because he can play
Rook captur on G5 and now Rook to E1
this again reintroduces the threat of
Pawn to H5 because if Rook captures here
then the bishop on E6 will hang so Rook
to E8 hun says all right you move the
Rook from the G file I move the Rook
from the G file so Andre brings it back
hunt also brings it back and here uh of
course once you see a repetition like
this you start the dreaming of a draw
but the stronger players will often
repeat uh positions just uh to to see
you know uh how how you're doing to see
if you are present psychologically to
see if maybe it rattles you but also you
know the uh it's sort of the the
gentlemanly thing to do so Bishop to D4
uh we have Bishop to D5 and now Bishop
to E5 going after the C7 Pawn uh
whatever happens on the king side will
happen on the king side there's no
stopping that but you might as well
snatch a pawn while you're at it so Pawn
to B5 and now Bishop captures on C7 we
have Bishop to E4 going after the C2
Pawn but now Rook to D1 going after Rook
to D7 check and now okay you could
prevent it with Bishop to D5 uh but it's
very easily stopped B3 again going for
C4 and if you stop that just Rook D4
starts collecting as A5 is impossible
due to Bishop covering the A5 Square so
okay hun says let's go for it Bishop
captures on C2 but now Rook to D7 with
check King to e sorry uh King to E8 was
played uh and now we have Rook to d8
with check King back to F7 another
repetition Rook to D7 check King to E8
and now we have Rook to D2 with tempo as
the bishop is hanging but now not
bringing the bishop back because then uh
Andre would even consider capturing The
Rook here he goes for Rook six to G7
attacks the B bishop and now just Bishop
back to E5 again with Tempo on The Rook
uh Rook to H7 goes after the pawn here
and now comes Bishop to F6 and what is
what is the idea here uh okay uh the
bishop is still hanging Rook to d8 check
is coming H there's really not all that
much to do here if you play Bishop D4
then The Rook on H7 is just stranded for
example Rook to d8 with check King F7
and Rook here will win the the H7 Rook
you have to go back and then just Rook
captures on H7 will win you the game so
Hans tried one last idea he played Rook
to f8 sort of to avoid checks and put
his King on G8 to defend the H7 Rook H
but it doesn't work Rook to d8 check and
he was in this position on move 39
before even reaching time control that
hunt Neeman resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here the
point is that after King to F7 of course
um you will not go for check and allow
King to G8 you will just play G6 with
check and that's it King captures uh you
will play Rook captures and f8 check
first and after the king moves you will
even play Rook to F7 check doesn't
matter King to J Rook Al on H7 you're up
a full Rook you have two connect pass
pawns uh there's I mean you you can win
this however you want uh so yeah after B
to the check hunts resigned and this
means a lot uh for for the standings
because now uh the leader is still
Michael Adams who won a very nice game
against jel Marda we've shown the
position he was lost but then uh Mard
blundered and Michael was able to win
the game uh followed by gou on Four
Points so Mike lens 4 and a half out of
six gkes four out of six am in tabatabai
three and a half out of six hansan clean
50% three out of six M Bartel three out
of six Andre voltin three out of six J M
three out of six then Nikita vov and two
and a half out of six Shas Ro two two
out of six and Luke mcshain on one and a
half out of six so we'll see what
happens it's still a very close
tournament Adams in the lead by half a
point uh will still uh he he already
played G cash so G cash if he wants to
win the tournament he's going to have to
do it somewhere else but like we said
gesh is playing H nean in the final
round uh we'll see uh we'll see what
happens uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it Berlin defense you
never know how it's going to go
sometimes it's going to be a nice
surprise like um uh like I mentioned in
the in the candidat stament in 2018
where Kik completely obliterated Aron if
you haven't seen it first link in the
description below mind-blowing game but
sometimes you know white will just
outplay you like this it was a uh The
Exchange sacrif wasn't even the best
move for Andre here but it it worked out
perfectly fine uh so yeah once again
really hope you enjoyed it I would like
to wish a very happy birthday to bushan
barade and I would like to thank David
gasparian grn rck schaer and Albert
vardell for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent and
rest of your
day